hey what is going on my little uh
coochie pies well I said appropriate now
a lot of us have different goals when it
comes to what we want to achieve you
know relative to fitness whether it's
for looks or health what you want out of
your fitness game is basically all
preference a lot of you have been asking
what my end goal is is specifically if
it's a vanity issue and so just to put
this out there yeah I don't give a [ __ ]
what I look like look now don't get me
wrong if you want to lose weight because
you dislike the way you look hey that's
all you that's your preference and I
support that 100% but for me
it's not the case you know there have
been a few people that wrote things
around this ballpark but recently
somebody wrote when I was younger a lot
cared about with my looks but David you
don't need a 6-pack to get a girl gonna
ask you something - what the [ __ ] could
I ever say my fitness goals were for a
girl hmm
and i'ma put this out there - I have
never had a problem time in women you
know why I'm a jackass y'all want to
know my secret this is how it is fellas
huh you just get rejected so many times
eventually one of them is stupid enough
to bite sir now sir now sir fine
whatever
gotcha Beach why is it that every single
person on earth thinks that your fitness
goals are directly correlated to you
getting the woman hmm-hmm now listen I'm
not stupid because I understand that the
physical laws of attraction are still
there but I got a great personality I
think right please agree oh how can I
break this down for you if my
personality was a body it would have a
six-pack huge biceps and a huge but
anyways back to that comment it's funny
how people who are always overweight and
out of shape love to use that as a
defense mechanism and as they come back
to everything but let me ask you this
what the [ __ ] does your personality have
to do with your health to that person
and all those people that make these
similar comments stop making excuses for
yourself if you want to live an
unhealthy life that's fine that's
perfectly okay and I support your
unhealthy lifestyle because it doesn't
affect me but for me I want to live
listen I didn't want to really tell you
my goals as of right now just because I
didn't think they were relevant to me
wanting to live a healthier lifestyle
but because you guys keep on asking I
will I love basketball and listen I know
you guys hear me make a lot of jokes
about me being out of shape
athletic and blah blah blah blah but
I've been playing ball my whole life
problem is about a year and a half ago I
fractured my ankle in multiple places
and I tore all the ligaments in them as
well yes it [ __ ] sucked
later on as I was finding out I started
developing knee problems for my knee was
hurting a lot and then of course I went
to the doctor to find out that I have
patellar tendonitis in my right knee as
well long story short without strength
training losing weight and Rehab I will
not be able to play ball like I used to
I'm at this point right now where
physically my body is [ __ ] weak on
the squat rack
I can barely rep 185 pounds and that's
very hard for me because this is from a
guy who used to squat 425 pounds on a
max load easy so for everyone out there
giving me weight loss and weight
training advice thank you and I
genuinely do appreciate it but for those
of you out there who have never weight
trained before never really worked out
and have all this speculative [ __ ]
that you're running on my page yes I
will no will I call you out no but trust
me as I'm reading those comments I'm
[ __ ] laughing at you so please stop
and you see with all this can be
epiphany that I genuinely don't believe
that your choice and being unhealthy
should stop you from doing the things
you want to do in life so I'm making a
change and I'm miserable right now not
because the way I look look at his face
but it is it I'm 26 [ __ ] years old I
shouldn't be movies like him on my
deathbed and as much as a lot of us hate
to realize this being fat has always
been something that we had to cope with
but was never probably now I don't want
any of you out there thinking that you
guys should have to be stick skinny or
come out with a six-pack I'm telling you
right now that I'm talking about living
a healthy lifestyle staying active
eating healthy indulging less and being
able to live a very happy life without
having to not do the things that you
want to do because of your health it is
a sad thing that we as people have an
option to be healthy but
counter-intuitively we choose an
unhealthy lifestyle for whatever reason
you guys want to lose weight and start
to live a healthy lifestyle that is all
on you and I support it 100% just make
sure that you guys do it in a safe and
proper way so Fitness fam always
remember that life is what you make it
and it's up to you to take what you
deserve
let's go for broke hey what is going on
YouTube yes I know in this video I got a
little bit more serious it wasn't as
goofy but there were some questions that
I just had to address so if you guys
were wondering where I workout it's at
barbell brigade right here out of
right part so if you guys are out there
you guys want to work out in a very dope
and positive workout environment make
sure you guys check your barbell Brigade
and I'll leave you guys a little link to
barbells a little site thing in the
description box yeah that's what it is
but if you guys were digging the shirts
that I'm wearing in the previous vlog
once again go for broke apparel calm yes
yes yes you can cut that gear over there
and remember before I leave for those of
you out there that are doing this with
me make sure that you record your
progress and tweet me that video and
hashtag it @ff or funny fat fit or both
hashtag 25 fit hash tag FFF and I will
go ahead check it out and give you guys
words of support thank you guys once
again for doing this with me and I love
you Fitness fam let's get it out there
let's get rid of my titties right here-
jiggle what-what-what-what fun wah-wah
disgusting and see i'm not stupid
because i understand that the physical
laws of attractiveness business is
present